welcome aboard the resolution it's a 45
year old oil drilling ship but it's
sailed most of its life as a science
vessel its crew navigated to soft spots
on the Earth's crust were rocks that
should be hidden deep Out Of Reach are
pushed up by the movement of the
planet's surface in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean lies a mountain the size
of Mont Blanc there's no place closer to
the Earth's mantle the mysterious layer
below the crust it's called the Atlantic
massive the Lost City
the scientists on board are studying
these places where life may have begun
but here what's happened is we've had
this faulting close to mid ocean ridge
which kind of pulled like this if you
imagine my fingers are the mantle
they'll be down there but they get
pulled out like this until they're on
the surface and we see the mantle and
Allure across them the only way we can
reach to get to these by direct drilling
is where there's a fault because these
rocks do not form on the sea floor
they find a borehole that was drilled
years ago using tools that can operate
at high temperatures without electronics
they drill and scoop up samples along
the way
they pull out the core lift it to the
surface in long plastic tubes and remove
the chunks one by one
then the science begins
they want to capture every detail from
the millions of years of history that
are embedded in each piece
so it's sliced loaded onto conveyor
belts and photographed
the splits we can see the inside of the
rocks and we look for
for variations in the minerals that we
see variations of the rock type
because it's here in the Alchemy of the
early ocean where chemistry may have
transformed into biology
when the greenish mineral Olivine
contacts seawater it burns in a chemical
reaction creating new minerals and
releasing gases through a process called
serpentinization
those gases like hydrogen and methane
may have been fuel for the earliest
forms of life
and understanding these reactions will
give Clues to so-called exobiologists
who are looking for similar conditions
under the icy oceans of the moons of
Jupiter and Saturn there's people who
are looking at this question of where
that boundary is by looking at how life
lives right now and trying to figure out
what's common across all living domains
and so what those earliest forms of life
might have looked like
the resolution is likely retiring its
annual U.S government fund of 50 million
dollars is coming to an end
the samples it digs up will be stored in
vaults for study in the years ahead
Colin Baker Al Jazeera